well the happiest place on earth is  looking to reopen by late april  after a year-long closure theme parks  and stadiums in california got the green  light to open with capacity limits  starting  april 1st so long as the county they're  in meets state standards according  to its color-coded tier system disney  can start with 15  capacity but with california residents  visiting only  while some are excited to get back to  fun activities the businesses  surrounding the magic kingdom  have been struggling for a year now and  aren't sure about opening their doors  we're just taking it day by day we'll  just see what happens  and plan but we're optimistically  looking forward to opening by  the summer at least another anxious  group so-called  legacy pass holders disneyland dumped  the pass holder program back in january  and has yet to announce a replacement  for those hardcore disney fans